[Music]
i got my drunk idea should we do some
drunk ideas yeah let's do it all right
so again to frame this
these are ideas that i had that i don't
think are good but i still want to say
them so i call it drunk ideas even
though i didn't have them while i was
drunk i was stone cold sober but that's
my cover story all right so drunk idea
number one
it's called
and you gotta you gotta tell me
i think i did this before and by the way
one gem came out of it which was my
lucky water brand uh that i i do intend
to create so you know
some gems do come out out of this so ben
you're a participant in this one i need
you both to give me your your idea your
reaction what's what should the scale be
on the reaction is it like
you know uh you know
so on a scale of sober to piss drunk or
like on a scale of like you know
horrible it's a good idea how do you
want to write these let's do one to ten
one to ten all right
first idea is called very long distance
girlfriend okay so i had this idea
because i realized like i'm sitting
there and me and my wife we like to
watch all these dating shows right so we
watch all of us blind we watch the
bachelor
and you watch these shows and this sort
of like it's like the honeymoon period
and i like i would say most people's
homes are like ours it's like
the scene is this on screen you see like
two usually beautiful people
living some kind of fairy tale date
um and then like one person's kind of
like you know there's some drama one
person's being dramatic or one person's
unsure and the other person's really
good or whatever
and then you and then if you if you
zoomed out off the tv you'd see a couch
with usually a couple sitting like six
feet apart from each other because
they're so sick of each other uh you
know there's like you know in their
sweats not dressed up with their you
know double chin
eating their popcorn and cheetos and
being like pointing at the screen and be
like ah she's not even that hot or like
oh he's you know he's such a jerk and
it's like
judging these relationships right but
like there's something to this of why we
like it right we like seeing these other
relationships but i also think
it's like when we do that we do that
with ufc like oh he shouldn't have
tapped out yeah dude he's such a [__]
he's still weak
he looks scared
yeah dude he's so scared that's why i
don't like him because he's scared it's
like yeah he's not confident oh my god
there's a spider in my room
so so yeah there's definitely like a
judgy there's a fun in judging it but i
would also say
there's a fun in the sort of fairy tale
like i think everybody when you're
watching these shows you sort of put
yourself in the shoes of either the
person pursuing or the person being
pursued you know you're that you're the
damsel or you're the prince whatever it
is so the idea behind very long distance
girlfriend is as follows
it's a service or app i think it's just
a service i think it's just a text
message this is a phone number you put
in your address book
and we give you the perfect boyfriend or
girlfriend
you're never going to meet with this
person it's not even the intention
it's just somebody who's going to treat
you
perfectly because they're paid to do it
and so so it's like prostitution it's
like what's a prostitute a prostitute is
somebody who's paid to love to love you
right to make love to you
but that's a lot not i don't want to
cross that line that's a lot of work
so this is like you know how tinder made
dating easier because you don't have to
like go date everybody you just sort of
swipe left and right easily on your
phone it kind of gave you this like
flirting hit but you didn't have to go
out put in a lot of effort so here's
what you would get if you if you sign up
for very long very long distance
girlfriend this there's going to be a
person that pretends to be your
girlfriend
they're going to text you they're going
to ask how you're doing they're going to
be emotionally there for you they're
going to text you baby photos of
themselves they're going to like you say
that they want you you're like oh my god
i'm this person wants me they're never
going to nag you
they're never going to get mad at you
they're never going to get jealous
they're never gonna do any of the things
that real human beings do and that are
the downsides of relationships only the
upside none of the downside so for girls
you're gonna get prince charming on the
other side he's gonna be complimentary
he's gonna be thoughtful he's gonna be
there for you uh and for for guys you're
gonna get sort of what you want as the
perfect girlfriend and we're just gonna
hire call centers
of
of just dudes and they're gonna behave
as your very long distance boyfriend or
girlfriend all right give me your give
me your ratings i'm gonna start with sam
i give that a 10. i i think that uh
i i think that's great to be honest i
think that surely that like if we went
to adultfriendfinder.com or something
like that is that what they do what is
adult friend finder what is that like
like webcam or you're asking the wrong
guy i don't follow your questions i have
no idea
um yeah i mean this is brilliant how
many friends do you have who you've only
met via texting and you've like i've
i've got like a bunch of friends who
have only ever
texted yeah exactly i have now most of
my life is people i only text with maybe
i knew them before there's a bunch of
people that like i don't know just
through twitter or through you know the
podcast or through friends of friends we
get a group chat together
i know their personality they're cool
like that's my actual friend even though
i never met them
so or even heard their voice or talk to
them like through voice and in fact i
have no desire to really meet them like
i don't want to go out of my way to go
like say hang out with them i'm getting
all the benefits that i want out of just
the text
yeah so anyway i have a lot of friends
like that and i consider them to be
really close friends i i i can't tell
you how tall they are what their voice
sounds like but i love them and so
because of that i'm in what do you think
ben
i give it a one it sounds diabolical it
sounds like a wine zero yeah or
just one zero
honestly a big slow roll for a 10.
there's this genre of idea of sean
business idea that essentially is i went
and watched an episode of black mirror
and said actually that's a good idea
and this is one of those but that's a
great great idea those are good ideas
yeah that's like
where do you think they're getting their
ideas they go to the great idea pile and
then they take a great idea and they say
okay let's put this to a logical extreme
where it actually turns bad
like have you remember that remember
that tv show in disney called smart home
where uh the the the it's like a smart
home it's like alexa
yeah and
the smart home ended up being the mom
and the wife so it kind of is like what
we're describing now so i think that
like yeah i haven't watched her i think
her is something like this it's like a
voice assistant that he kind of falls in
love with i haven't seen that but again
it's not even a fall in the love
it's just dude it's fun to get
certain types of text messages right
it's fun to get a funny text from a
friend it's fun to get something
interesting text it to you that's kind
of what the hustle does the hustle just
sends me some interesting stuff every
morning the milk road tries to do that
here's some interesting crypto stuff
right we're your friend but i'm not
really your friend i'm just sending you
some cool stuff you like getting that
message
but that's for the work part of our life
what about the personal side ben are you
telling me
you would i mean i know what you're
going to say you're going to say no but
let me just put it out there anyways
you're telling me you would not want to
be getting texts from
a woman who's so into you and it's not
cheating you're never going to do
anything it's not even a real person
you're never going to see him nothing
like that especially if you're single
right like i'm not talking about like
we're all i think we're all married men
right so so it's not for us this is for
25 year old me not
30 i don't know how old i am 34 year old
me
yeah i uh obviously we're not the target
demographic all of us because we're all
married um
but
having said that like even if it was
just like a as a as a a friend type
thing i like i already have actual
friends that i don't text back the last
thing i need is another thing that's
literally just a person to not text back
i don't need another one of those in my
life but fair enough maybe it's a bad
idea
but no no as a as a business idea of
course it's a good idea of course it's
like this has money-making potential
as a thing that is good for humans you
know
that's that's why i gave it one oh i'm
not i'm not in the group
i just felt like i had to be the
conscience here i had that one person
had to be like sean you know this is
okay okay it's good you know i'm the of
the devil you're the angel on the
shoulders we have to be there yin and
yang that's how it works that's good uh
yeah you know if you want good things
you should uh you know go eat your
vegetables work out you know wake up and
pray do all the things right like that's
cool
don't invest in russian companies yeah
don't invest in russian companies don't
have the very long distance girlfriend
servers for 19.99 a month don't um
you know
don't use tick-tock don't do any of the
things that you do probably all right
next idea
it sounds related but it's not it's the
huge beds company you kind of alluded to
this earlier
i've been thinking about the luxuries of
life that i care about
we all we all know what i do private
chef
personal trainer at my house
i live like a king
the one thing i don't live like a king
with is my bed is only
king-sized but a true king would not
have a king-sized bed true kings have
what's called a
emperor-sized bed have you ever heard of
these
no
so athletes have these i saw these
because there's a woman who has this
business it's already a great business
there's a woman who makes beds for nba
athletes and so shaq has a 24 foot bed i
believe of like 24 foot like in diameter
and um you know a whole bunch of
ambulance players do this they have 12
foot diameter beds 18 foot things like
that the room it's like it looks
ridiculous but the whole family can
sleep on there and still have their
space uh like you know just to get to
your spot on the bed you kind of have to
crawl there like a small child just to
your pillow like because there was such
a long runway and so
i've always saw these and i thought
these look super comfortable and i've
decided i want a very huge bed and i
realized i wouldn't know where to go buy
it so my idea is a ddc brand
called
huge beds name tbd we need we need a
better name no no no keep it it's like
it's like it's like uh the company big
ass fans
yeah it should be big ass beds okay
that's the next beds big ass beds
for badass people
[Laughter]
marketing slogan included with my drunk
ideas all right so so big ass beds and
basically it's just a dc brand that
sells you this right like these are very
expensive so these these run for like 20
20 000 on average i think is like the
cost of these like humongous oversized
beds and that's why athletes buy them
because they're a the nba players are
already very tall plus they got a lot of
money so it's like the sweet spot for
them and this woman who they buy it from
this is one woman and she just sells it
all through her instagram basically it's
like
some player posts a picture of his bed
tags the woman people go look at hers
she has like an instagram full of huge
beds people go buy from her
so i think that's just like a niche that
somebody could go own big ass beds and i
think you know okay athletes is one
but we need to find a new niche we may
need to go into a new sport or maybe
maybe it's business nerds who are trying
to optimize their sleep and it's like
you know you make up some mono jumbo
about this having a big bed is not gonna
make you sleep better unless you're like
eight feet tall
have you tried it
well maybe maybe it's like a free-range
chicken maybe when you're not confined
by this you know like maybe you have
anxiety all night because you might fall
off the bed right maybe just being able
to stretch out
is nice
right maybe maybe not being so cramped
is nice i don't know seems like there's
some benefits
there definitely maybe is but definitely
probably isn't i mean haven't you been
in a cal
haven't you been in a california uh
king-size bed before i have a california
king-sized bed yeah you have a challenge
you have a california king
a california king is like the same size
as a king it's just longer instead of
wider it's the same overall size it's
just longer
so it's not the same overall size but
yeah i don't know it's the same size but
it's like less wide more long are the
other ones more wide less long you have
a californian times with baby
that's a huge bed if you ask me that i
think that's big is that not is it just
you and your wife in the bed or do your
kids stay there sometimes my kids stay
there and my dog so it's like you know
we got a full house in the bed
i think that likely there's another
thing that should be addressed than
making it bigger
yeah like don't let
i would call it i would create it how
about we call it uh i thought we'd
create a little kid bed company or a dog
bed yeah or we'll call it a crib or we
can make like a dog bed business
also a good idea
i think maybe those are the solutions to
your problem instead of making a 20 by
20 a 400 square foot bed
ben what do you got here it seems like
you might be on my side sam is so wrong
on this but i
i have a king size bed it is a good size
uh
i don't what is good good enough for you
no i don't want to be anywhere near my
wife when i sleep i want to have to
shout for here to hear me like there's
always like just some little toe poking
me in the middle of the night and if you
could just offer me i never have to
worry about that a b you're right sam is
it gonna actually give me better sleep
probably not is it gonna be an amazing
experience to just like crawl onto this
massive
piece of luxury that is 20 feet long yes
it sounds like an amazing experience and
i want it i want to feel that and you
can see a third of your day on this bed
right you're spending eight hours on
this bed
why not
just
the second that you said like a 20-foot
wide bed i just knew i wanted it my
heart knows that i wanted to see the
pictures when you see the picture you're
like this looks like lavish as [__] all
right so
uh do you guys one question do you guys
sleep with a pillow in between your legs
of course i sleep with the maternity
pillow same so i have a body i have a
body pillow and so i like basically
spoon the pillow because i need my my
knees to be i i can't have that's just
straight ergonomics that's just like
that's proven that's not even like us
being weird that's us being scientists
so the reason i use my wife's pregnancy
pillow is science
do you really you use her what is she i
bought two so i so i bought hers
i bought her one because my buddy my
buddy told me this my buddy goes
congrats you guys are pregnant fantastic
so happy for you hey get your phone out
and go to this website you're gonna buy
this swedish pillow
it's 200 but trust me best pillow ever
and i was like oh my god like never been
so intrigued by a sales pitch took out
my phone ordered it right there i'll
never forget where i was i was in an
uber in las vegas when this happened and
i thought all right and it's like it
says like five weeks to ship i was like
oh my god
this must be fantastic if it's like such
a shitty experience and so uh it arrives
it's amazing
my wife uses it she's like it's good i
was like only good he really built it up
let me try it out i try it for a nap so
good i ordered myself one and now she
never just uses she never uses any of
them i use both of them actually and i
it's fantastic what's it called
uh i'll have to look it up it's uh it's
like some swedish name that i don't
really know
yeah i'm a big fan of those i'll i'll
buy one i just had like a really long
pillow that i just kind of spoon but
maybe i should buy one of these
it is called oh here it is
bbhugme.com so the two letters bb then
hugme.com bb hug me uh and it's designed
in scandinavia so that's not swedish
scandinavian and uh just look at it it
just looks like it's gonna be good and
then it is good it's really it's really
great really great pillow
all right i'm gonna buy one of these wow
this looks huge yeah it's not that big
but it's like kind of like
it's like got like beads inside or
whatever so it sort of like forms to
your body it's great
all right i'm on board with this i bet
these guys crush it by the way
yeah i can imagine the things really i
think it's pretty expensive it's like
200 for one pillow which is a great site
a lot um all right so here's my next
drunk idea i got two more for you
hoa court
okay so do you guys have an hoa where
you live
no i'm no you one time if i
remember correctly sean you had an hoa
just for a
duplex didn't you yeah yeah me and me
and our other person we had a hoa with
an hoa fee but we both as soon as we
bought the place we were like yo we're
not gonna put 400 into this every every
day right like and we both just agree
we're not putting 400 a month into that
do you have an hoa ben
yeah and i kind of hate it
so
my hoa has been harassing me lately i've
been getting letters so i rent i rent my
current place and uh we live in this
neighborhood
and there's some karen in this
neighborhood that just hates me and
she's like oh i don't like that you you
know leave the trash bins out a little
you know an extra day i don't like that
you work out on the like street in the
driveway like you no exercise no
exercise equipment is allowed i'm like
what is that are you exaggerating really
no no
there's three complaints there's that
there's that and then there's another
one which is um we get like water
delivered like you know like kind of
like a water dispenser so you get these
jugs five gallon jugs and so they're
like kind of like they're like the guy
delivers it to our door but he tucks it
behind this pillar so if you're looking
at our house you can't even see it you'd
have to like walk up to our like walk
halfway up our thing to go see the thing
and so somebody just keeps complaining
to and our landlord's like dude what's
going on is it look he lives in another
state so he's like what is this like can
you just are you like [__] up things
i'm like no i don't do anything wrong
okay the trash i do leave out a little
bit um but you know besides that it's
not a big deal like when you're working
out the street is it like just you and
your trainer and what are you doing is
throwing a medicine ball or something no
we're doing lunges it's like dude i can
lunge in the street there's nothing or
like we have a battle rope that we'll
put on a you know but that's my driveway
dude i can do what i want in my driveway
um and so
in my neighborhood's like mostly really
old people that like don't really do it
do much so you know i get it but i'm not
disruptive anyway so so this hoa thing
and so i first was like i was like okay
i have two choices i can either just
quietly resolve the issues just listen
just move the trash cans in put the
battle rope inside the garage only move
it out when i want and uh water jugs
like i guess i could pull them inside
the door uh it kind of takes up space
but you know no harm done no you cannot
do those though nothing no no no number
one it's not happening right right this
is war and so i went to war so i was
like you know what
i'm gonna waste my time and energy
fighting this hoa who is this hoa after
all i demanded names i demanded to speak
to somebody i said they can call me
direct next time they have a problem i
said here's my number i put it out there
i started to um i said i started to go
take photos of other houses i said i'd
like to file some complaints myself oh
what is this children's swing in the
front yard this person has violation why
is this person's garbage cans outside
violation why is this person riding
their bicycle exercise equipment on the
street violation and so i started
fighting back i started saying is it
because i'm the only brown guy in the
neighborhood just
i was i was waiting for the race that
you had to do that you had
i can only wonder what's so different
because again i see violations all
around me now and so i'm i am basic but
there's no my my complaints are falling
on deaf ears and i'm wasting a bunch of
time i need hoa court it's a judge judy
likes show
streamed onto netflix and or youtube
where i can go present my case and it's
a place for petty people to do their
thing and that's that's my pitch this is
actually a show it's a tv show hoa court
or petty court pity yeah maybe petty
court maybe penny is the right way to do
it
i think that's beautiful but isn't this
do hoa people not have uh what's that
called where um before you go to court
you can hire a um arbitration
arbitra uh an arb
yeah arbitration mediation yeah uh is
there what do you do with hoa how do you
know who wins
you can't win that's the problem hoa is
this like you know ambiguous force that
just controls you even though you you
you know you pay your hard-earned
american money to uh to live in this
place to buy this land to live free but
the freedom's not there and that's why
we need petty court to bring back our
freedoms and to put put these petty
people back in their place
do you
do you um
like
do you just like reply all to an email
well no it's like they they use these
agents like cowards there's like a
there's like a random hoa email address
with like one person behind it's like no
who's complained is the majority of the
neighborhood complaining maybe it's a
democracy maybe we need 51 complaints
for me to change the way i do things why
does one person get to change my way of
living right that said it sounds a
little crazy to me so i just feel like
there's no justice and then when there's
no justice i can't sleep and that's what
i i i want to dig deeper on this because
i actually think that it's totally not
worth your time to fight this this is
this is a fight this fight always
certainly not worth my time no it is
definitely these fights are worth our
this is what living is for i love doing
this stuff i love fighting with
neighbors and like trying to win and
like rub their face in it like a dog who
pees inside i love this
and so is there a way i don't believe
that's considered the best practice
anymore by the way for dogs for dog
training
i don't deal with h.o.a i don't want
peta coming after us is there
is there a way that you can set a trap
and figure out who it is
um
i don't know how i would do that um oh i
know
i put a unique letter under the doorstep
of everybody in the neighborhood i say
listen
i heard about the complaint and i
understand
in fact
i'm sorry that i did what i did
um
you know i would just love to make it up
to you what's your favorite flavor
chocolate or vanilla i'll send you a
treat because you were right and i was
wrong and i just need you to know that
you were so right with your hoa
complaint um
so just shoot me your hey just text me
your favorite flavor honey pot gotcha
that's actually pretty brilliant and you
can do one of two things you could
either say this person's a flavor this
person it's a what size t-shirt you are
or you could just get a bunch of
different google numbers
and
see which ones no no even better google
i say hey have you guys seen this
[__] who lives over here
guy keeps putting his fr he keeps doing
lunges in the street am i right like
violence in our neighborhood
i think we should escalate this he's not
listening
uh
i believe it was you who made the
complaint but maybe i have that wrong
if it was you i'd like to discuss steps
of how we might escalate this issue to
make sure that jerk goes down
if you bring them in bring them close
before i put them put them away
i i i would love for you to do this how
many people live in the neighborhood you
think
uh how many people are part of an hoa
no it's a neighborhood it's everybody's
defaulted in there's probably i don't
know like 100 maybe 60 houses 100 houses
or something like that it's a lot of
time and energy you may have to like
shut down one of my businesses just to
do this
you don't think you know who's doing
this i have no idea
really it hurts me because i know
there's somebody who walks by smiling at
me while i'm working out in my garage i
just work out my garage with the with
the door open just have some air right
like it's no big deal i'm allowed to do
that in my home gym
you can't change your behavior you have
to continue doing it
well i've already
bent but uh you know i've brought the
water bottles inside and i moved the
trash cans but you should buy lawn
chairs and put them in your front lawn
and just hang out there without a shirt
consistently i think that's what the
move has to
be that's a gift to the neighborhood all
right um
last idea
all right the nba all-star game just
happened
and um
and every sport has this and baseball
has the home run derby
uh football has the pro bowl nba has the
dunk contest and the all-star game
why doesn't this exist for business
is that a thought that's ever crossed
your mind why don't we have the tech
all-star game why don't we have the
business the business all-stars
i feel like there's there's an
opportunity here to bring together
the who's who
well i'm just going to use tech for now
so bring together the who's 2 of tech
just the all-stars
honor them
get them to compete for our
entertainment
and uh just make a weekend out of it
right why aren't we why are we treating
this like the sport that it is so here's
here's how this might work tech all-star
game is basically a hackathon and i get
zuck and i can get larry page and sergei
sergey and i go get founders of
different mega companies and they're
going to perform it's going to be live
streamed onto youtube and they're going
to have to build something they get 24
hours to build something so you have an
all-star designer you got johnny ive
working with mark zuckerberg all of a
sudden you got brian chesky working with
you know uh
whoever you know
sundar or whatever you get you pair
these guys up into random combinations
and they're gonna have to do a hackathon
they're gonna have to build something
and demo it and somebody wins the trophy
for building something cool because
you've seen that like darmesh
loves to hack and build little projects
i remember when covet happened kevin
systrom the guy from instagram he built
this dashboard that was measuring the
viral coefficient the spread because
he's like hey these politicians are just
like making statements and we have no
source of truth no dashboard that tells
us how this thing's spreading and how
it's not per city and that's what we
need to look at and so he built this
dashboard there and i just thought huh i
wonder what would happen if you
unleashed these types of brains the
all-stars in a in a little competition
of their own a little hackathon of their
own what do you think of this idea i
think if you can if it's if the if the
idea is like an award thing then i think
that's the worst idea you've ever had i
think that's a horrible idea if you
think if it's like a hackathon no one
will ever do that but i think it's an
interesting exercise and that and here's
my question to you if you took let's say
mark zuckerberg jeff bezos
um
the google guys and the ceo and you had
them do a hackathon do you think any of
them are actually still capable of
making anything
like making it but you it would be them
on their own so you'd pair them with
like
every team is
they also an all-star engineer so
all-star technology person an all-star
designer and an all-star ceo product
visionary no that's [__]
if you want one-on-one if it's just that
like for example
bezos can't probably build anything he
might you know he's gonna go build like
a blog well like if it was
if it was like you and me it's like you
guys like you gotta go make like a
business in the next like week i'm i'm
very confident that just me on my own i
could build something that makes money
do you think that uh one of the google
guys sergey and larry page
do you think that they're capable of
actually making anything maybe like i
know zuck can so zuck when when snapchat
came out i remember that
uh he recognized the threat that was
snapchat so early on
and created facebook pokey literally
wrote code into the facebook poke like
their their competitor that they i think
they released it in nine days or like 19
days or something ridiculous
and he was one of the lead engineers
actually writing code in the project now
he doesn't normally do that but that was
like the story at least
do you think i think he could i think
very few others could i remember so mike
michael burch who who built bibo he was
a programmer right he's a programmers
programmer he built
four or five startups that were all
interesting and successful and we did a
hack week and i invited michael i was
like michael come hang out don't just be
mr investor you know far away like come
hang with us live in our like we're
staying in your cabin so like just come
hang with us and he came and i was like
you wanna you wanna build something
we're all building this little like you
know apps and uh he's like well um don't
exactly know javascript like the
languages i know aren't really used
anymore and i don't really remember a
lot of it and i haven't coded in years
my machine is not even set up to do it
so uh you know i don't even know what i
could build at this point and so he
cooked us dinner instead
and then later he got back into
programming he's like oh yeah like okay
now i got my machine set up i'm you know
i'm using python i'm learning the new
languages instead of the old stuff but
he like ramped up over time and now he
loves to code he codes all the time but
i think when i put him on the spot when
he hasn't been doing it no he was it was
tough for him to just like go build
something even though he was an engineer
let me tell you something real quick
this this isn't that shocking because i
didn't exactly own a tech company but i
made a i owned a company that made tens
of millions of dollars on the internet
when you use words like python and
javascript or whatever you said i have
literally no idea what those are
like for real i don't know how
progressive try to guess what what is
python well it's like a language but i
don't know like i don't know what you
use it for i don't know what it does
when people talk about like ruby on
rails i'm like so there's like a java on
rails like how like is there like i i
literally don't know what the words are
these rails you speak of yeah yeah or
they'll be like well this is css and
this is html and this is i'm like i
don't know like is one of those like the
outdoor sighting of the home and like
like i do like an analogy does it i
still to this day i have no idea what
they mean this is like when i told you i
you know i go into home improvement
they're like okay so is it a dry wall or
and i'm like
it's not wet like wait wait what do you
mean can you give me four or five types
of walls with some photos and i can tell
you which one it looks the most like
okay can we do like a prison lineup here
and i'll point to the wall that looks
most like my wall
like when people talk about this stuff
so the way that we worked at my company
was i would sit with the engineer and i
would just draw i'm like the website
it probably should look something like
this and i'll write the words that i
should say and once you click this
button let me draw the second thing that
you should see and i would give them
i would give it to them and it would
work somehow and i and i to this day i
have no idea how any of those things
work
yeah and who who needs to i used to i
used to be like oh i wish i knew how to
code i'd be so much better if i knew how
to code and i would love to learn how to
code i'm still actually i'm still like
kind of at night i'm taking this like
you know udemy course on python or
something like that and then our buddy
suli was like he's like yeah people say
that and he's like i used to know the
code he's like uh he's like dumbest
thing ever who cares how to code he's
like you could pay somebody
here here's a guy in india he can code
whatever you want you just tell him
he'll do it
he's like
knowing why
i actually totally disagree with him i
think that the key is at least you knew
how to do it so then um and if you don't
want to do it anymore that's fine but i
actually think that when
there's been times where i've talked to
my developer and in my head i'm like
well you just got to click this button
and you see this and they're like well
you don't even have to click the button
you know like this technology the way it
works is you can i'm like
that works that's a possibility like i
don't even know i wish i knew how to
code so i knew what frameworks i could
like work within because when as someone
who doesn't know how to code i'm like
how do you how did you i didn't know
that's possible like you know what i
mean it's like asking someone in 1800 to
like explain to them how text messages
work it's like whoa whoa whoa what the
hell is a phone let alone you know what
i mean and that's how i feel sometimes
when we're talking about coding so i
think that's true i actually agree and
disagree with what he said so i agree in
the sense that i used to think
i used to have this story in my head
that if i if i knew that then i'd be
able to be do so much more and i don't
believe that that's true i think that
anything i wanted to do i could do by
just
you know hiring one of many many
programmers out there or using a no code
tool it is actually not holding me back
and i can get the same result whether i
do it or not the part i disagree with is
i think it's really awesome to be able
to have an idea in your head and be able
to make it happen yourself because
there's a huge
lossiness in trying to explain to
something else explain something that's
in your head that's kind of fuzzy to
somebody else having them download your
fuzzy picture then they output it in an
even fuzzier way it's like a telephone
and it comes out very different a lot of
times like when i write something or
like if somebody says all right uh can
you help me write this email i'm like
yeah but you've got to give me the
keyboard and they're like well i'll like
i'll type it and i'm like no you don't
understand like i don't just think of
the email i write the email and while
i'm writing it i think of what to say
like i i can't create content in my head
i create it while i'm doing it and i
think most great things that get created
are like that you're building it and
while you're building it you're sort of
like figuring out what you want to build
and like playing with the idea live and
that's what gets separated when you're
not the builder yourself and so i i am
jealous that i don't get to do that when
it comes to building apps and let me ask
you one more question so let's just say
that we took um some of the big folks i
i actually i won't use elon because he's
proven it but like you take the guy who
started snapchat ev evan i think uh
yeah
zuck
the google folks bezos maybe not bezos
because he's also proven it but you take
them
and you strip away like what they've
done
and they're the same age but you know
they've just been like an insurance
agent their whole life um
do you think
in one scenario do you think that they
could still accomplish something great
and then on the other side let's just
say that they decided at the same time
when they were young 19 and starting
facebook let's just say that like you
know instead of facebook i'm gonna focus
on like music or or this like music app
like still tech but just like a slightly
different version do you think that they
would be even remotely as big and
successful as they as they are
so the second question i think is much
easier to answer which is i think all of
those people would be very successful by
any like kind of objective measure
but would they be
people that we know their name we talk
about them and they're you know hundred
billionaire you know status no
you know i do not think that's true i
think luck plays a part in the magnitude
of the success but not the probability
of success so i think all of them the
probability of success for them is all
90 plus percent they would all be
good at what they do
positive impact you know
make millions of dollars over their
career
and be like considered top of their
field in whatever field they go to the
magnitude of success the fact that they
end you know basis ends up being worth
hundreds of billions of dollars that i
think is
um
much more luck of the bounce on which
opportunity you took versus others um
so yeah so that that's kind of my answer
to the segment what would you say
i agree i think that so for example
there's this guy named david carp you
know who david carp is
he's the tumbler guy right he invented
tumblr and tumblr basically sold to
yahoo i think for
a billion was it was it a billion it
sold for a lot of money but he's totally
then they shut it down tumblr's totally
non-existent anymore and he uh he
doesn't i don't even know what he does
he just he's not relevant and i think
that a guy like him who i've seen talk
and i've heard and i've read his writing
he's pretty brilliant and i'm like man
if tumblr had not sold or if you were
working on something else i think you
could have been way better another one
is the guy who created meetup um scott i
think his name is
he is amazing too but meetup is not that
big of a that wasn't that big it wasn't
that interesting i think if that guy
would have worked on something else it
actually would have he would have been
significantly more successful and and
some of these guys it's kind of like
they're lance armstrong and they're
riding the two to france in a mountain
bike or with a flat tire it's like man
you that was needlessly hard if you
could have been way better if if you if
you just picked a different thing level
10 hustle level 10 skill level 6
opportunity right meet up to me is like
a level 6 opportunity it was just like a
really hard space to go into he did the
best of anybody who went into that space
we all know the name because of that
reason but meetup just wasn't as big as
not meeting your friends in real life
and only talking to them online through
facebook right like facebook was just a
far larger opportunity and i don't think
it was that zuck knew that so i don't
think it's that they're
so kind of like
um big brain that they just they filter
out bad ideas like best idea i think you
know like there's a lot of text messages
that get leaked from zuck early on and
he was he thought wirehog was gonna be
the the real thing he was like you know
still
debating i don't know if i should do
facebook when facebook was like already
a thing and working and he's like he's
like i think you know this is this stuff
that we're doing right now is going to
really help us when we do wirehog
which is like a file transfer protocol
that he just thought might be bigger and
you know obviously at some point he
recognized no this is the opportunity
let me do this but like it's not like up
front he just said i analyzed 100
opportunities and i've identified the
one that's going to be this app that has
like billions of users i don't believe
that that's true at all i think you sort
of look into the size of the opportunity
and the era that you were born you know
these guys if they were born before the
tech wave they might have just been the
best blacksmith in town and not had like
any of the tools that let you become 100
billionaire because there was no
leverage available to you you know 100
years ago or whatever
yeah i uh by the way
michael chandler and justin gaichy they
uh they fought like a
three months ago these are two ufc guys
and they're both known for kind of being
like big meat heads who just stand in
the middle and bang and hit each other
really hard and they don't there's
they're just kind of crazy and justin
gaichi at the end said something amazing
he goes
i love that he had just suffered this
like three round war where they were
banging each other in the head as hard
as i can and you feel sad because you're
like this guy is gonna brain damage and
at the end he goes what just happened i
love it he goes i feel like i was born
in the wrong era i should have been a
roman gladiator because i would have
loved to fight to the death in front of
all you people
and i and i heard that it gave me chills
i was like i believe you i your you and
i are not the same you're you're crazy
like you are built to be a warrior and
sometimes i think about that i'm like
who today like or i i think like who was
like like alexander the great if we put
him in like today's era like would he
just be like too brutish and we'd be
like dude you're an idiot bounce like
get out of here you dumb idiot or like
if napoleon came into play nowadays like
it's kind of like a dating app
yeah like what would like what would
like the gladiators of them be working
on now like were they just like well
let's ask our historian ben you study
these guys what do you think if you
transplanted alexander the greater
napoleon into this era or edison would
he be like what are you a dating app
really that's so stupid or would you
think that that's the coolest thing ever
and he goes i wish i could have done
this
i doubt edison would be into dating apps
but i like i was on my alexander the
great episode one of the
points i made is i was just reading this
book about alexander the great and it
talked about a contract that he
negotiated with one of his contractors
one of his suppliers to move
their baggage train from one area to
another and i was just like oh
this is like not that different like he
had contracts that he had to negotiate
and he had suppliers who provided his
weapons and like logistics and he just
contracted them out and he had people in
charge of the contracts and like had
basically kind of the same organization
that ceos have so
i think like yeah so alexander the great
i think he'd be a
his personality he'd probably be like a
ceo
uh
edison would be like a
entrepreneur
kind of technical but moves out of it
like a zuck like yeah
yeah that's interesting i i think about
that all the time uh about like what
like the
the
you know people who dominated from
hundreds of years ago what would they be
like today and vice versa i'm like dude
if if zuck didn't learn how to use a
computer like would that guy have just
been a dork like in the 1800s like what
could he even have survived the plague
like you know what i mean and so i think
about that all the time
um cool guys i gotta run all right end
of episode
[Music]
you